in your book on the future prospects for
humanity
you imagine a time machine that allows
you to send a tweet-length message to
scientists in the past like to newton
yes um what tweet would you send it's an
interesting thought experiment what
message would you send to newton
about what we know today
well i think he'd love to know that
there were planets around other stars
um he'd like to know that uh that would
really blow his mind he'd like to know
that everything was made of atoms
uh he'd like to know that if he looked a
bit more carefully through his prisms
um
and uh looked at light not just from the
sun but from
from some flames he might get the idea
that uh different substances emitted
light of different different colors and
he might have
been
twigged to
discover some things that had to wait
two or three hundred years
could have given him those clues i think
it's kind of it's fascinating to think
to look back at how little
he understood
people at that time understood about our
world mm-hmm
well if you think about astronomy um
then until about 1850
um uh astronomy was a matter of um um
the positions of how the stars
and the planets moved around etc
of course that goes back a long way but
newton understood why the planets moved
around in ellipses but uh he didn't
understand um
why the solar system was all in a plane
what we call the ecliptic
and uh he didn't understand it no one
did to the mid-19th century what the
stars are made of i mean they were
thought to be made of some fifth essence
not earth earth and water like
everything else you know
and it was only after 1850
when um people did use prisms more
precisely to get to get spectra that
they realized that the the sun was made
of the same
stuff as the earth and the indeed the
stars were
and uh it wasn't until
um 1930 the people
knew about nuclear energy and knew what
kept the sun shining for for so long so
it was quite late that some of these key
ideas came in you know which would have
completely transformed newton's views
and of course the
entire scale of the solace of the
galaxy and
and the rest of the universe just
imagine this came later what he would
have thought about the big bang or even
just general relativity absolutely
gravity just just
him and einstein talking for for a
couple of weeks
[Music]
would he be able to make sense of
space-time and the curvature of
space-time and well i think
given a quick course i mean he was sort
of
if one looks back he he was really a
unique intellect in a way you know and
uh
he said that he
thought better than everything everyone
else by thinking on things continually
and thinking very deep thoughts and um
so he was a utterly remarkable intellect
obviously but of course scientists
aren't all like that i think it's the
one thing that interested me having
spent a life among scientists is what a
variety of uh mindsets and mental styles
they have yes um and um um
well
just to contrast
newton and darwin um
darwin uh uh said uh uh and he thought
correct does he
that he thought he just had a um as much
sort of uh
common sense and reasoning power as the
average lawyer
and that's probably true because his
ability was to sort of uh collect data
and think through things deeply um
that's a quite different kind of
thinking
from what was involved in a in newton or
someone doing abstract mathematics
i think in the 20th century the coolest
well there's the theory but
from a astronomy perspective
black holes
is one of the most
fascinating entities to have been
through theory and through experiment to
have emerged from obviously i agree it's
an amazing story that uh um
well of course
what's interesting is einstein's
reaction because of course although
as you know we now accept this as one of
the most remarkable predictions of
einstein's theory uh he never took it
seriously even believed it yeah um
although it was a consequence of uh
exclusive his equations which someone
discovered just a year after his theory
schwarzschild um but he never took it
seriously and others did um but then of
course um
well this is something that i've been
involved in actually finding evidence
for black holes and that's coming last
50 years and um
so now there's pretty compelling
evidence that they exist
um as the remnants of stars or big ones
in the centers of galaxies and beyond we
understand uh
what's the what's going on we have ideas
vaguely how they form uh and of course
uh
gravitational waves have been detected
and that's an amazing piece of
technology ligo is one of the most
incredible engineering efforts of all
time that's an example where the
engineers deserve the most of the credit
because the precision is well as they
said it's like measuring the thickness
of a hair at the distance of alpha
centauri yeah this is incredible tends
to minus 21.
you